as a monster he identifies as a little
dog well when he sits on aisle five and
fights a little girl in aisle six you
call me I will talk about what your
problem well talk about which one's the
problem that happens there call the cops
and tell them that that dog took a [ __ ]
in that bag come on that's okay I think
that this sprites a transaction out with
me out no no help with the complete
unfettered tolerance for any forms of
self-identification nowadays it seems
like anybody regardless of race color
size sex or gender because those are
different now are free to come and go as
they please when they please wherever
they please however whoever whomever
whatever they are what are some still
getting the short end of the tolerant
stick like my dog you've no doubt seen
them in your grocery stores malls and
restaurants little rat dogs once shunned
by civilized society now allowed to roam
our human establishments at will that's
not gay Jerrod my producer he spent all
day walking around with that dog not one
person had a lowly mr. Lee tipper for
two or three okay how do you want to
count it good how you doing
she's fresh she's fresh she's our little
angel
Oh loeli loeli but we stay fresh and
busy got your helper yeah we say we stay
Queen the Queen Sheba Queen
two three really three four your bestie
we say Prussia pull over feel the
feeling it
she's okay right is she okay great
success now contrast that with hopper my
ninety pound dog Oh Argentina who just
so happens to identify as an eight pound
lapdog he's always been this way so who
are you to judge we wanted to see just
how tolerant of a giant white monster
people would be come on come on hop come
on
I'm sorry but with that let's go with
yes
does he look best no he doesn't
these two have the best I can buy him
the best hi how are you gonna believe
because we cannot have a dog in the
building okay why is that
you got that guy's got his dog there in
his little in his little knapsack he's
not going he's not bothering anybody
Sue's my why is he still here calm your
horses they're okay sweetheart I'm
having a drink with my friend are you
going shade on me oMG this is not okay I
will leave as soon as as soon as
sweetheart here goes takes a special
kind of crazy to willingly admit that
you're twice a week regular at macaroni
grill part of me always had to wonder
was it the dog or was it me not gay
Jared speaks and acts with a certain
effect ation that causes people to cut
him a wide swath very tolerant Lee some
of them I start shopping with monsters
walking around it up and down every
aisle that's your color that's your
color right there
you enjoy your pitbull sir how are you
doing good time to treat yourself
oh these are Cooper where's Betty
Crocker makes type of ways no my
goodness
those are some big [ __ ] Ben and Jerry
later I just I can't even I can't even
whilst all ability to even so I decided
to see if it would work for me I mean us
and then he identifies is like a little
dog so we take him everywhere
you know sometimes tackle somebody but
it's it's all in good fun
hi these two items thank you very much
oh it's this it's it's a she identifies
of the sheep let's go into it's not for
me I I I'm gender-fluid I identify I
identify as a woman I just have to use
the potty real quick it's not the end of
the world I'm just tinkling nothing I
just want to try on some clothes ok can
we use this know what because I don't
identify that way I'm pansexual I'm
gender-fluid and I was just a target and
they let me use the women's room okay
thank you I appreciate you accommodating
today well not a whole lot of value
except that people just aren't as
tolerant as they think they are
especially when it comes to big dogs who
identify as Bichon Frise z-- and also
that you can pretty much get away with
whatever you want with a little bit of
confidence and a lisp like going into
the women's changing room with a 90
pound monster and a beard finally small
dogs are gay